hello and welcome to the 15th a PHP
tutorial in this tutorial we're going to
be discussing defining your own
functions and also the use of global
variables so with that let's hop right
in and just define a quick function
defining function within PHP is pretty
simple let's say we'll call this
function and we're going to define it as
global zip and we're not gonna have any
parameters later on you can specify
parameters but with any function you
don't actually have to have any
parameters and then you'll have curly
braces and then as usual whatever you
want to happen within it so first we're
just gonna echo this is a basic function
and I'll give me it for our function now
once you've defined the function the
next thing you have to do is actually
let me show you what happens when you
run this script without actually or when
we only defined the function top over
here refresh anything it's actually an
empty page there's no air or anything
but just empty and that's because
nothing's happened the point of a
function is to save yourself from
repeating code basically so if you're
going to continue calling function or
calling the code within the function
over and over you might as well just
call it you know define a function and
then every time it just calls this so
already even though we've only made a
one-line function if every time you
wanted to echo so I'm a string of text
all you have to do is type Global's like
this instead of this whole line so let
me show you so to call this function all
we have to do is do Global's and then
the import thing save that and when we
run it that's all we had to do even for
this string so as you can see even with
our one-line function it already is
saving us time and then if we continue
running this
we could call it again so we could say
echo let's just echo pray and then
Global's one more time and save that and
let's run that are we in here save that
refresh and now you see this is a basic
function it's a basic function so as you
can see like that is kind of the purpose
of a function now what if we wanted to
do something different like we want it
to say hello in your name how would we
do that well let's do variable call it
name and my name is Harrison so we'll
naturally call it give the variable name
the value of Harrison and then we want
to echo hello
. here's my so we want it to say my name
so let's go ahead and save that and run
that and see what happens yeah well come
over here refresh and you should we got
hello but it didn't give me my name
right for some reason it's not pulling
this in there so to get the global
variables like within at least within
Python at the top of the thing you just
before the functions you define they
make any variables you define within the
function is only going to work you know
that way within the function whereas in
PHP it's not quite that like that so if
you've got a global variable that you
want to reference within a function
you've got to do global and then you
give the variable that you want to act
like a global variable so now let's save
that and now let's run that and see what
the difference is mother trucker
like I already know what I've done wrong
every time I see that I'm just like I
didn't have the semicolon I see parse
and I'm just like it anyway so now you
can see it says hello Harrison and so
and then obviously a very very basic
function but as you can see already
we're saving a lot of typing just by
defining this function now since we're
here let's go ahead and discuss
parameters so the parameters is kind of
like a way to specify a variable and
then define it when you call the
function so a way to do that is and if
you recall I guess we haven't really
done me like serious functions besides
like print or write print Mar was a good
example when we printed the array the
the way that function is set up it's got
a parameter in there that you can fill
and in this case you fill that parameter
with the variable that is corresponding
to the array and so it knows to do that
with that variable so in this sense like
let's say instead of defining name
anywhere we'll actually even call it
something different like we'll say we'll
call this variable program name so you
just you just pick that variable here
let's camelcase it be good little coders
per am name and then what we'll do is
come over here and instead of saying
hello
just name we'll say hello Graham named
since that'll be the parameter now still
we haven't defined anything here but the
way that you define it is within the
Global's so in here we can say let's say
your name is Ben instead so we'll just
do that and let's save that and run that
and see how that works
pop over here fresh and as you can see
now it says hello Ben right and so
that's kind of how the parameters within
the function works in the next like what
if we do let's let's do something else
let's do mathematics so let's do math
and let's say this is num1 and then we
want another bar that will just say is
num2
and this time we want to echo out the
result of let's just do number 1 plus
like that and so now when we do we call
the function of math we can save 1/5
right so this should you should echo out
6
don't forget your semicolons so anyway
we'll save that and pray for a 6 and not
a parse error and sure enough there's
our six new parser nice and always see
you can do all kinds of things and you
can really put unlimited number of
parameters in there that you want so
anyways those are this really basic
functions what you can do with them and
the whole point of functions as always
thanks for watching and until next time